du nord
[Musique]
casimir de rang corps qu'est ce qu'il ya
casimir de ranko mais attendez j'arrive
il paraît qu'ils devaient aller des 50
adela il a repeint de la cuisine il
faudrait veiller à les deux bouts
casimir où il dort tellement fort qu'il
n'entend pas aller casimir
maintenant y'a rien à faire attendez il
ya quelque chose qui réveille casimir à
coup sûr je sais pas quoi vous n'avez
pas une idée qu'est ce qu'on va faire
des bruits d'animaux
ben oui on va essayer d une idée de
muriel qu'est ce tu veux faire et ben
vas-y tu lui fais vite alors elle est
tout près
on va voir si ça
[Musique]
allez continuez c'est bien mais comptez
réputé
bah c'est très bien mais que pas
l'impression que ça soit efficace
brigitte lamy mais non
et toi qu'est ce que du magistère
nathalie le chat allez on va lui faire
le chat il va se croire dans une
basse-cour rien à faire et toi claude
qu'est ce que tu veux lui faire mais bon
on essaie le cobaye mais j'ai pas
l'impression que ça ce soir allez vas-y
et toi sophie tu veux pas lui faire
quelque chose c'est vraiment trop bête
qu'on ait oublié ce qui pouvait
réveiller quelle famille et bien tant
pis lido avec trop fatigué alors on va
le laisser dormir tranquillement a alors
on va s'en aller sur la pointe des pieds
pour sûr pas le dérange au haut à quoi
qu'est ce que c'est maintenant la seule
chose qui réveille casimir c'est le
silence complet et vous savez pourquoi
et bien parce que dans sa famille il
ronfle si fort qu aucun bruit mais
réveille roi est alors un os
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est un petit oiseau des îles un petit
oiseau de couleurs si tu le vois parler
dans la grande île on suit le et
connaîtra pas d'un si tu veux bois
vendée dans la grande île
sui loïc par des trappeurs
[Musique]
quel est le même
c'est un petit oiseau des îles qui est
entré dans mon corps
il s'est posé dans la vie tranquille et
marie je m'appelle bad
marie-jo matin
m
[Musique]
depuis ce jour là je vis
un peu comme au paradis
et si tu veux boire l'amour rien on chez
moi partout
[Musique]
donner la main à main
c'est un petit oiseau des îles qui
mangent au creux de ma main
c'est un temps
trois offres âgées qui chancerel chez le
matin c'est tintin
toisant fragile qui chantent sous la
douche le matin
[Musique]
mais la leur
m
depuis ce jour là je dis un peu comme au
paradis
et si tu veux voir l'amour
d'ailleurs chez moi
[Musique]
c'est un petit oiseau des îles un petit
oiseau de couleurs
si tu le vois aller dans la grille suis
le mec qui connaîtra le valin situe le
boy-band à la grandville suit le équipe
connaîtra le bonheur
[Musique]
si tu le bois volé dans la grandville 6e
et qui connaîtra de bonheur si tu
doivent aller de l'avant il suit le et
tu connaîtras le bonheur
[Musique]